you are loved you are perfect i pulled
out a pride flag that was hiding in my
back pocket and put it around as a cape
17 year old senior josh ocampo loresca
speaking out after attending homecoming
saturday night at durango high school
ocampo loresco was named homecoming
queen a proud member of the lgbtq plus
community josh pulled out their pride
flag and gave a speech in which they
shared with fellow students to love
oneself that speech quickly turned into
a kampalareska being walked off by
school administration ocampolareska says
they were told prior that flags of any
kind were not allowed at school but told
it was the commotion of the speech that
led to them getting in trouble i was
talked to by administration and i was
told not to pull it out because of any
political statement it might carry my
identity should not be controversial in
any sense of the matter and with or
without the flag sunday josh's family
spoke to school officials and josh is no
longer facing any type of disciplinary
action but josh and their friend alex
say it's important they feel comfortable
at school and that everyone is accepted
for who they are the ones that do get to
rare pride at school should not be
punished in any way or told that they
can't do that even if it is
covered with a different narrative
josh plans on going back to school on
monday and says the school
administration has since apologized for
the misunderstanding they say on their
part reporting live from durango high
school madison kimbrough live local now